[Music]
let's go to mitch in boise idaho mitch i
love that name what's up brother
good morning dr john how are you doing
good man how are you
doing okay thanks for taking my call you
got it so what's up man
so
um
i um
in a relationship i guess you would say
at this point um
hold on man yeah you guess i would say
at this point sounds like y'all are
madly in love man
are you in a relationship or not in one
well let me explain
several years ago
i started dating a woman and at first it
was long distance
um
as time went by she was able to move
closer
um we started to become serious yeah
started talking about about marriage
and then you know
big things are children religion
and money
and so
when we started doing things like
traveling to see
builders and architects she became very
nervous
when i sat down to talk about you know
my financial situation she
became very nervous
she would miss appointments to talk
about
her financial
situation
and
it's just things got really weird really
quickly
how old is she
um she's probably in her
early 40s
how old are you
uh late 40s okay
has she been married before
um
no she has not have you
no i have not engaged not married okay
and then
at the end of all of this
it turns out that i didn't know who she
was and i mean that on all levels
i didn't know her parents i didn't know
where she grew up i didn't know where
she went to school i didn't know um did
she lie to you anything about her
yeah i didn't i didn't know her name
john
so she she was like living a lie all
this time
a very very
elaborate life whoa
and in the end
she
started having depression
alcohol abuse
suicidal ideation i'm trying to
work with her to get her treatment but i
want to move on yeah why
why
you're married i mean you're dating a
fraud
yeah i am
but i'm worried about her kids i'm
worried about her i'm worried about her
doing harm to herself
yeah i mean there's a there's a
humanitarian responsibility there which
i get and you need to put her in front
of professionals that can do that kind
of work
is this some i mean
i'm speaking for you maybe you realized
everything was an elaborate lie after
all this time and you're you're cool
with it and you're like oh that's cool
shake it off we'll i'll forgive you and
then we'll let's move on let's create
something now under
a reality i mean is that where you're at
or you want out of this thing
no i'm i'm done because i i tried that
once and then there were more things
came to life yeah dude i mean
this is heartbreaking because you
thought you were going to spend the rest
of your life with this woman have you
sat in that for a minute
yeah yeah like this sucks
yeah no i'm i'm
i mean i'm i want to move on but i don't
want to move on under a lie under the
next person without having you know
ended it with with this person i'm
concerned if i ended with this person
she was going to end up
in a bad bad place yeah and she she
might be
um your responsibility is to treat her
with dignity and respect and to
call 9-1-1
it's not to
continue a
like a
janky
stumbly romantic relationship a romantic
relationship with somebody just because
you're trying to
like help her out that's not helping
anybody
in fact that's part of the ruse that's
part of the game
is that she'll drag you along and you
become like a
like a leaky
oxygen tank for her until she can find
the next thing
damn
yeah man if you're done be done
with bold conviction
and she's made some choices she's got
some she's got some significant
challenges
yeah yeah um but she took advantage of
hell yeah i've been together man
um about six years now
yeah so that's hard man
slicing my life on yeah yeah
and my hope is you can sit in that grief
for a season and then look back and say
even though it was a lie you all had fun
you did laugh
right there was romance i mean it's not
with the person you thought and it's not
in the way you felt i mean the whole
thing i don't know dude that's hard man
yeah not even hard that's devastating
let's use that word
and you you have you ever listened to
the show
um
this show no i've heard you uh on the
rams okay
on other shows um
so you probably haven't heard me say
this one of the most devastating things
about what you're experiencing
is a somebody lied to you and they
played a long game on you and that's
devastating it's unnerving
but what i find most often
is that mitch suddenly doesn't trust
mitch anymore
like how in the world did i miss this
and every new person you meet is this
big like well my signals were off last
time i don't know and it comes across as
you don't trust them
but often the the major distrust is in
you and it's unnerving because you don't
know which way to walk anymore because
you don't trust your feet anymore you
don't trust your eyes you don't trust
your heart you don't trust anything
anymore
and you got to own that otherwise it
just will it will affect every new
relationship you're involved in
and you thought you won this one huh
[Applause]
like i can just imagine you 40 you're 44
you're 43
you're starting to think like man this
i'm just gonna be a single dude
and then you find somebody and then she
moves in and moves out and whatever and
then suddenly you're like you allowed
yourself to believe is that right yeah
yeah yeah it's a good way to sum it up
you're going to slide into this deal
under 50 have the last back half of your
life to ride or die with somebody and
dude she's a fraud i hate that for you
man
i just don't want you to minimize that
and again i'm i'm speaking to you and
everybody listening i want you to
minimize how big of a deal this is this
is heavy
yeah
so are you you're done done done
yeah yeah i mean there's no
nothing to build on when trust has been
betrayed over and over
in a huge way there's just no way to
build it from it so y'all live together
no so what does a breakup look like for
you
breakup would look like
a phone conversation
um
that can you do that in person no
uh
[Applause]
yeah probably could
probably shouldn't so here's what i
would recommend after six years of
somebody who's um
made a series of really unfortunate
character choices and is probably
struggling with a lot of
um
physical mental health challenges am i
right on both of those
yeah i think there's a lot going on
with her that
needs uh she needs a lot of help okay
most of the time folks in this situation
create a breakup event
and it's got a lot of prelude and a lot
of talking and a lot of
hugging and crying and negotiating
and what i would recommend is putting
your thoughts in a letter
and
having an in-person conversation that is
on the whole very very short
but is this going to be a stunning
surprise to her surely she knows this is
coming in some shape form or fashion
well she knows i'm definitely not happy
with her okay i think that's part of
what's led to the alcohol abuse and et
cetera et cetera okay
um so and this is the same with when you
have to fire somebody this is the same
when you're breaking up with somebody
this is like
the conversation should be 15 minutes 10
minutes
this relationship is is officially done
um i am ending this relationship i don't
want to talk with you anymore if you
want to like my heart is in this letter
right here and here's what that does it
allow as soon as you say those words
boom her ability to think
critically is off she's in fight or
flight
so her thinking brain is off her
survival brain is in full she will say
anything do anything and some of that
stuff will be true some of it will be
i'm so sorry and then it will get into
threats and i'm gonna do this
if you write it in a letter she can go
back to it over and over and over and
over again
and she can't begin to misconstrue and
mischaracterize what you say and how you
said it
and so a very clear facts are your
friends
i'm standing at the doorway of a home
ma'am your husband was in a car wreck
today and he has died period
just like that
not well there was rainy outside it was
a darker stormy night nope here's
exactly what happened that's what i'm
recommending with you is to have an
in-person conversation
and let her know this conference i mean
if that's where you're going with it if
you get in that conversation and you
choose that you want to stick with her
great um but i'd spend some time
processing that thing and then man
please go talk to somebody even if it's
once or twice
just to get all of that
out because you got to rebuild some
trust with mitch man
okay
and if you think she's going to hurt
herself
make sure you've got 9-1-1 there or if
you need to have a social worker with
you or if she's got a
psychiatrist that you want to reach out
to
you can call her counselor her
psychologist or psychiatrist and say i'm
going to be terminating my relationship
with this person today or tomorrow they
can't call you back they can't even tell
you
that they're seeing her but i don't know
that yeah but they can't take data one
way
okay and they may know oh crap i need to
reach out and what you're doing there is
you're putting the impetus on the
professional
you are saying you are equipped to deal
with this i am not i'm not a suicide
expert i am not a crisis response expert
you are so here you go
i'm calling 9-1-1
and that's where your responsibility
lies there
and i know this sounds harsh and
clinical
um i don't want to see you get dragged
into the next nine months if i'm gonna
kill myself i'm gonna not kill myself
because you're not equipped to handle
that that's not your that's you don't
have the skill set to deal with that is
that fair yeah yeah that is that's true
cool
man i'm sorry brother
okay i'm sorry well i appreciate the the
direction anything else i can help you
with
i feel like it's a bummer call man i
don't know i wish i could have given you
like oh dude just say this it's gonna be
cool i
oh right but it sounds like you call
like you already know man
i oh yeah i mean i i knew i knew it
wasn't going to
i don't know get better it's just trying
to find a way to to
take my life back
yeah
so
well dude i'll walk with you if you want
to call back after this thing's
like the smoke clears a little bit and
like now what's next man i'm happy to
walk with you on on that side of it too
okay
all right
thank you very much all right brother
i'm grateful for you mitch